(audience applauds)
- I am so sorry I missed
you the first time.
- That's okay.
- I was sick.
Your co-star though, hosted.
- Yeah, Kumail, he did a good job.
- Didn't do as good as
this is going to be.
I'm just kidding,
I'm just kidding.
(Quentin laughing)
Anyway, let's talk about the new show
"Tiny Beautiful Things."
- Yes, yes.
- That's an intense scene we just saw,
so who do you play?
- I am Danny, I play
the husband to Claire,
played beautifully by Kathryn Hahn.
- Mm, love her.
- And we're just kind of going
through the everyday life,
you know, being married,
having a 16 year old
daughter, trying to raise her
while she's going through her transitions
and us having our problems ourselves
and trying to find ourselves really.
- Yeah.
- And it's--
- Which can be difficult if you do this.
- Exactly, growing apart,
it's grounded and it's messy
and I'm just really
excited to be a part of it.
Beautiful show.
- Did you know her before this?
- I did not, I did not.
- So wait, you're in such
an intense relationship
in this movie,
so how did y'all kind of
start that relationship off.
Did y'all do anything to prepare?
- I mean the casting
process was really fast too.
Got casted on a Sunday
and we had to be going 10 days after that.
- Wow.
- Yeah, we wanted to bring to
life this 16 year relationship
between the two of us, at the very least,
'cause that's the age of our daughter.
And so we decided to meet,
we decided to go on a hike
and we did this thing
to have the 36 questions
to fall in love with somebody.
- Wait, what?
Is that a thing?
- Yeah.
- How have I never heard of this.
- Like a New York Times article.
So we go through and we're hiking
and we're asking each
other these questions
and Kathryn comes up with the idea like,
we shouldn't just answer as ourselves,
we should answer as our character.
- Oh, smart.
- So then we're doing
this and we kind of find
our backstory together in these questions.
- And then develop that chemistry.
- Yeah and it was just super organic.
- What are the questions like?
- Well actually, I brought a
few of them, if you want...
- I want to know them.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Obviously I need help falling
in love. (audience laughs)
Like whatever.
- Okay, all right cool.
So let me see, a good one for you.
So they have ones like this, it's like,
would you like to be famous?
In what way?
And that's not a great question for you,
'cause you're famous. (audience laughing)
So we're not going to do that.
- Let's set that one on fire. (laughing)
That ship has sailed.
- Okay this is a good one.
Before making a telephone call,
do you ever rehearse what
you're going to say? And why?
- Okay, no, but I should. (laughing)
I should definitely at least
have some bullet points.
- And see that's my thing,
I like to rehearse and
then I like to make sure
I say it in the best way.
Because sometimes--
- That's smart.
You're going to do well in relationships.
- It just comes off.
We'll see.
- Yeah, yeah.
Is there one more, lets do one more.
- Yeah, yeah, let's do this.
And this one I love.
- I want to do one more.
I love this by the way.
What a cool way to connect.
You should do this with every person
you do a movie with.
- I don't want everyone to
fall in love with me though.
(audience laughing)
- Yeah you do.
Yeah you do.
Then you shouldn't have walked out here
looking like that.
- Put the button back.
- That's your problem.
- Yeah exactly.
Okay for this one.
- Okay, one more.
- So for what in your life
do you feel most grateful?
- Oh this is going to be a cheesy answer,
but it's my children and here's why.
Because I didn't think
I'd ever get married
or have children.
Not because I'm frowning
upon either one of them,
just because I've always been a very...
I'm a musician at heart,
I'm kind of just always this wonder
and I love wondering
and so I never thought
that would happen to me.
So that's pretty magical
to have loved someone deeply
and to have children is pretty great.
- 100%, that's so interesting,
not to go off on...
When I watched you on "The Voice"
you have such a motherly loving vibe.
- Which is so weird,
no one that knew me before
would ever have been like,
"you're going to be a mom." (laughing)
- Wow.
- Just because I'm naturally that person
that I feel like a lot
of artists in general
unfortunately can get a bit selfish
because you're so consumed
with whatever you're doing
and is always a high
priority in your life.
I feel like I lived my 20s
pretty selfishly in a good way.
Like I got to travel the world,
got to do all these things.
Where I'm from, you're like
dead if you have babies at 31.
So you're like an old maid.
So I started late in the
game from where I'm from,
but I love that I waited
because now I really appreciated that time
and now I get to appreciate
these little beings
that are so magical.
- That's awesome.
- Yeah.
Can sometimes be hard. (laughing)
(audience clapping)
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
For sure.
- They give you gray hair, but it's fine.
Okay, let's do another commercial break.
Everybody I love those questions.
You can see "Tiny
Beautiful Things" on Hulu.
It's streaming now.